so last time we kind of went through red
flags a little bit but you know some of
these things maybe triggering to some of
my listeners and to that I say too
[__] bad that's kind of what I said
on on the last last episode we did so
going into a couple of the
flags I know that one of them is
definitely the uh the parental
challenges that some women have right so
they either have daddy issues or mommy
issues so sure go to go into a little
bit as to why that's so troubling for
someone for a guy looking to date
somebody with those issues well it's it
starts with a premise I think that
you're a strong virtuous leader of a man
right because if you're some plugged in
beta male that's just like you know goes
with what the cultural narratives happen
to be at that time um none of these
things are going to make it difference
for you and if we're being honest this
is for guys that don't want to invite
chaos or chaotic women into their life
uh because they lead and they have the
capacity to choose you know let's be
honest a lot of guys don't have the
capacity to choose and the first girl
that touches are peee they want to you
know get husband and wife things going
on
so um you can't have a relationship with
any of these women that have any of
these red flags that I talk about in
this list and by the way you can get
this list for free by opting into my
email uh list if you go to my website at
rich
cooper.com but these are the things that
popped up the most often I think I put
daddy issues at the top simply because
it's just it's not good I mean if you're
a strong virtuous masculine type of guy
you're a leader you're putting a dent in
the universe you know how to make Bank
you're captivating you're influential
you're not a boring guy you've got a
good social network the last thing you
want to do is deal with a woman that
doesn't respect um a man I think the
strongest influence in a woman's life is
her father and the sort of role that he
plays in the world view that she uses to
assess the world is incredibly important
um
I would uh recommend all guys
contemplating a woman on a long-term
basis uh be comfortable in the sense
where they would sit down and just hang
out with their girl's dad for hours and
have a conversation about anything and
be totally fine and comfortable that's a
good sign a woman that didn't have a
father around the first thing they
always say well how is that my fault
maybe that's true it could have been um
he was a loser and he ran off it could
have been um you know Mom pushed him out
of the household uh and he and it was
just intolerable and he just decided to
stay out of the way uh either
way it potentially may not be her fault
but it would be her fault if she carried
the baggage into perpetuity you know a
lot of women will just um want to carry
the victim card and want to be like oh
poor me um I'm this poor victim things
aren't fair and that's one of the red
flags you know by the way is you know
women with a victim mindset um so being
able to work on any deficiencies that
they have personality wise or baggage
wise I think is incredibly important but
it's pretty common now I think most guys
understand that women that don't have a
good relationship with their father uh
tend to have Daddy Issues they tend to
have uh BPD uh borderline personality
disorder um they tend to have
abandonment issues often they'll act out
in ways uh with men in relationships
that will ensure abandonment um just
because of their behavior and the way
they behave so yeah sure you know you
can have a Rel ship with one of these
girls but it's not going to be easy it's
not going to be fun it's not going to be
comfortable she won't be a compliment to
your life it'll be difficult it'll be
more difficult than a woman that doesn't
have daddy issues that has a good
relationship with her dad for sure
definitely it's just I I think we and
you and you brought it up someone who
say the mother kicked the father out of
the house maybe he was an alcoholic or
he just wasn't a good parent maybe he
was abusive so a an obvious response to
that from women who might have had this
growing up is they would say okay well
this wasn't n exactly my
fault what would you say to them if a
woman came to you came on your show rich
and said hey I you know I grew up with
father that just really wasn't good to
any to to me nor my siblings does that
mean I don't deserve love you know what
what should I do about it what would you
kind of say to her well I think one of
the fundamental problems that arise out
of the situation is mom's got to take
some of the blame for this too right
because she chose Dad she like he didn't
accidentally fall in her and nut in her
like there was a there was a conscious
decision-making process that they went
through and she decided to say just go
and me it's safe or whatever um
so there's got to be some ownership
taken for the decisions that she made
with who she chose as the child's
father the problem that I've noticed
with a lot of these women that choose
terrible men as fathers for their
children is they often spend a good part
of the children's formative years going
on about how men ain't [__] woman needs
a man like a fish needs a bicycle you
got to go out and you know make sure
that you don't have to rely on anybody
you got to get a degree or three um make
sure you have a
career um and I think that a lot of
these single parent households um you
know where moms didn't have a father
around and they had to raise their kid
by themselves is unfortunate uh but it's
the reality of the world that we deal
with and I think it's it's it's probably
what has formed a lot of the uh single
women today that are well under the 30s
40s and 50s that are all boss girls and
career women and you know they've got
their Ikea furniture and their Tesla and
their degrees on the walls usually with
some student dead as well um but they
don't have a man in their life and
they're unhappy and they're single
because they prioritize themselves and
didn't really do the work to be a good
compliment in a relationship um so again
like at the end of the day once you're
an adult whether you're a man or woman
it doesn't matter to me but once you're
an adult and you realize that there's
deficiencies if you want to take
ownership for them you should work on
them you know there's people that can
walk you through that sort of stuff I
don't do that that's not my area of
expertise I'm not a specialist in that
area but there are trained uh
practitioners that that that deal with
trauma childhood trauma and um dealing
with the baggage I think is incredibly
important but um I think one thing that
a lot of guys have noticed as they sort
of deal with women you know as they get
older um there's a lot of gals out there
that that carry around a lot of baggage
you know they never and they just never
get rid of that Lu
AG right yeah
it's it's very hard to look in the
mirror and that's why it's very
interesting that you have so many I I
definitely tend to find this more common
with women who end relationships always
thr out the the toxic uh my dad was like
this to my mom or you know my mom or my
stepdad or my mom's boyfriends or
whatever it happens to be it's like okay
well there's a common denominator here
right I mean you know what I mean you
chose this person
if you continue to choose the same
people and they keep and you end up
getting the same result I think uh
Albert Einstein's Insanity definition
kind of reings true I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clip's from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out